[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt les
territoires sur tv5monde et sur vos
chaînes locales et régionales de la tnt
voici tout de suite les titres de
l'actualité
les taxis ralenti par le coronavirus les
professionnels du secteur sont fortement
impactées par le recours au télétravail
et la baisse du nombre de courses il se
félicite donc de la fin des restrictions
reportage à suivre à saint-etienne avec
tl7 la télévision de la loire elle aussi
compte bien profiter de la levée de
toutes les mesures liées à la pandémie
les stations d'hiver elles se préparent
en ce début de vacances pour un mois de
février bien remplie comme le montrera
la chaîne 8 mont blanc en savoie ou un
polo moderniser et adieu la casquette la
police nationale sera bientôt équipé
d'un nouvel uniforme après la célèbre
marque balenciaga et il ya 20 ans ce
sont aujourd'hui des étudiants qui ont
conçu la nouvelle tenue tv7 la chaîne du
groupe sud ouest a rencontré
quelques-uns de ses créateurs encore en
formation
à la fin de ce journal nous lyon à
monaco s'est tenu un match pour la bonne
cause d'anciennes stars du ballon se
sont affrontés avec le sourire vous
verrez pour récolter des fonds dans la
lutte contre le virus hiv on débute donc
ce journal avec cette bonne nouvelle
pour chacun d'entre nous la levée de
nombreuses restrictions liées aux copies
de 19 depuis mercredi fini le masque en
extérieur ou les jauges dans les
enceintes sportives
le télétravail quant à lui n'est plus
obligatoire mais recommandée
un changement qui profite notamment vous
allez voir pour les taxis en effet à
cause du télétravail certains chauffeurs
ne réalise plus que 50% de leurs courses
et regrette même la période du
confinement et les aides de l'état alors
pour se relancer les professionnels
attendent aussi avec impatience la
réouverture des discothèques prévue le
16 février prochain reportage à
saint-etienne d'adrien bletterie pour la
chaîne tn 7 regarder
11h ce matin à la gare de châteaucreux
et les taxis sont totalement à l'arrêt
ils ont appris à patienter depuis
l'obligation du télétravail le coup de
massue pour les taxis stéphanois et de
tout d'ailleurs également c'est celle au
pire en fait tu puisses télétravail
celle au pire on n'a jamais connu ça
actuellement si les attentes en station
de deux heures tout à l'heure à
l'hôpital nord de saint-etienne pour
avoir une petite course parfois parfois
ça peut être une grosse mais est il
beaucoup moins de 1000 cas là également
donc en fait on est dans la tente obligé
de prendre son mal en patience quand on
voit son nombre de courses fortement
impactés avant j'allais dire
entre 20 et 25 courses par jour papa
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui je dois être
beaucoup
il faut bien manger 1 donc on est là on
m'attend et même si la levée des
restrictions va aider les taxis à
retrouver du travail il faut tenir bon
en attendant et s'adapter c'est plus
difficile à l'heure actuelle que lors du
premier confinant pourtant très dur
puisque on avait les aides de l'état
lors n'a rien du tout donc c'est
beaucoup plus dur et puis la date du 16
février est attendu avec impatience et
les courses vont augmenter grâce à la
réouverture des boîtes de nuit
notre grande actualité en france cette
semaine c'est la crise de confiance
envers les établissements d'hébergement
pour personnes âgées dépendantes les
ehpad une crise suite aux révélations
effrayante du livre les fossoyeurs
concernant la gestion du groupe privées
orpea le gouvernement a notamment
annoncé l'ouverture de deux enquêtes
cette semaine
pour autant tout n'est pas si noir dans
la gestion des établissements à limoges
vous allez le voir la ville vient
d'organiser le déménagement de son
centre communal d'action sociale un
nouvel établissement fonctionnel qui
accueille désormais professionnel et
héberger un reportage d'alain druot pour
7 à limoges sur place
c'est le grand jour pour les résidents
et le personnel de l'ehpad marcel faure
en une journée tout le monde quitte l'ex
maison de retraite pour s'installer dans
un nouveau bâtiment conçu aux dernières
normes d'accueil et de technologie plus
de 100 personnes âgées des ménages
ça va changer le cadre architectural
déjà un bâtiment plus vaste que claire
plus lumineux des couvoirs voilà où il
fait bon circuler les résidents vont
trouver une chambre du couple plus
colorés avec une salle de bain contenant
une douche qui n'était pas le cas
auparavant et puis des espaces de
convivialité qui n'existe pas une partie
des 100 résidents des ménages est
particulièrement observée par l'équipe
soignante pour éviter toute impression
de malaise avec la perte des repères
habituels et préparation d'un bon avec
des visites aussi bien pour les
résidents dans la mesure du possible et
les familles élément extrêmement
important dans ce déménagement
et on a mis en place les dessins
protocole en cas de désorientation
importante du sujet âgé pour que
l'infirmière ne soit pas démuni
vis-à-vis une situation un peu
compliquée dans les extraits perdre
vaste mais adapter le nouveau site a été
pensé pour le confort des résidents et
la qualité de vie au travail a lorsqu'il
change déjà la capacité d'accueil bien
évidemment puisqu'on a sept places de
plus mais on est surtout deux étages
deux mois donc une certaine
rationalisation je dirais des
déplacements des agents des familles et
des résidents et puis on a surtout un
établissement qui est pensé pour
accueillir une personne âgée aujourd'hui
au sens où on l'entend
voilà et puis nadia et était l'invité de
face aux territoires ce jeudi sur
tv5monde
la ministre déléguée chargée de la ville
ancienne députée de trappes a notamment
été interrogé par as though tayrac
depuis le siège de la provence à
marseille azotés rate c'est un fighter
de mma qui travaille pour la réinsertion
des jeunes grâce à son sport il a
notamment interpellé sur les difficultés
rencontrées par de nombreux jeunes dans
les quartiers une question qui fait
suite à la nouvelle fusillade survenue
mercredi soir à marseille et qui a causé
un mort et fait un blessé
regardez
auteyrac qui est un champion de mma de
sports de combat qui est un marseillais
qui est un habitant des quartiers
il a failli tourner mal son frère a été
assassiné devant lui il a tourné mieux
tourner bien il a réalisé au moment de
ce drame que sa vie ne pouvait pas aller
dans ce sens et c'est grâce au sport il
ya une question à vous poser depuis
marseille azotés rac je travaille dans
l'éducation populaire
et en particulier dans la prévention et
j'aide les jeunes à ceux à se réinsérer
avec le sport de combat et la question
que j'aimerais bien vous posez madame la
ministre
c'est que diriez vous à ces jeunes là
pour pouvoir les motiver ces jeunes qui
n'ont pas de
qui n'ont pas d'objectifs et à cause de
ça ils se tournent vers des choses pas
très
pas très bonne pour eux
d'abord bonjour azotés rac et merci pour
cette question ce que j'ai envie de
répondre à ces jeunes c'est qu'il n'ya
pas de fatalité aujourd'hui dans notre
pays qu'au xxième siècle en france on
peut réussir on peut réussir si on suit
cette voie républicaine cette offre
républicaine et pour cela nous
multiplions les moyens nous multiplions
les moyens sur la prévention et j'ai été
vraiment ravi d'entendre ce mot de
prévention parce que c'est une politique
nous avons trop souvent écartés pour
remettre dans le droit finalement
raccroché certains jeunes qui sont en
marge de la société à ce qui fait
société et donc nous multiplions les
moyens en matière de prévention un
soutien massif aux associations nous
redéployons des éducateurs et des
médiateurs aussi formés à la prévention
spécialisée donc pas de fatalité c'est
le message que j'ai adressé à ces jeunes
la république elle est là et elle va
justement vous aider vous accompagner à
la réussite
voilà plus dans l'actualité la tendance
ne vous aura sûrement pas échappé lors
de vos achats les prix de certains biens
connaissent une forte augmentation ces
dernières semaines faire son marché sans
trop dépenser est devenu un véritable
casse tête pour les consommateurs en
martinique que fruits et légumes ont vu
leur prix s'envolaient la raison un
climat chaud et des produits qui
deviennent de plus en plus rares un coup
dur pour les clients mais aussi pour les
marchands qui doivent s'adapter aux
tarifs des producteurs écoutez ces
quelques réactions au micro de loïc que
régis de la rédaction de via à tv sur
place oui j'ai vu une grosse différence
est d'à peu près 5 euros en tout sera
pas nier quand on fait nos achats ici la
différence elle est plus de deux fois le
plus de 25 à 35 euros en fait il fait
très chaud dans les champs et les
produits s'abîme donc ça les prix se
répète ça se répercute sur les prix
au niveau du marché
de la martinique aux montagnes enneigées
de savoie dans ce grand jt des
territoires les vacances scolaires
d'hiver débutent ce week-end pour une
grande partie des écoliers un moment de
la saison est évidemment attendu dans
les stations de ski françaises qui
profiteront de la levée des restrictions
sanitaires c'est le cas par exemple de
la petite station de combes ou en haute
savoie où les chiffres s'annoncent déjà
très positif un reportage d'emmanuel
jaune pour la rédaction locale de 8 mont
blanc regarder
si les pistes de combloux se partagent
aujourd'hui aisément entre les quelques
skieurs présents l'ambiance va
radicalement changer dans quelques jours
avec le début des vacances d'hiver les
touristes sont attendus en nombre dès ce
vendredi 4 février remplissant presque
entièrement les quelques 4000 son lit
touristique du village on va osciller
autour de 80 2% sur la première semaine
82 à 85 ou encore des réservations de
dernière minute qui sont en train de se
faire la situation sanitaire a quand
même raccourci le délai de choix des
vacances des vacanciers et puis sur le
reste de la période dont vous oscillez
entre 70 et 80% en sachant que les deux
dernières semaines soit un tout petit
peu moins bien rempli que les deux
premières face au mont blanc les
commerçants et hébergeurs combes laurent
ont donc le sourire car pour de
nombreuses structures l'essentiel du
chiffre d'affaires de la saison se joue
sur ces quelques semaines qui
s'annoncent d'ores et déjà chargé là on
est plein pour les vacances de février
il reste encore quelques petites dispo
en semaine mais bon et voilà c'est de
bon augure disons on a eu quelques
annulations mais pas plus que ça
finalement parce qu'on a une clientèle
plutôt française nous
dans cet hôtel
elle n'a pas vraiment ressenti les
effets du co idée on ressent que les
gens ont besoin de sortir de s'évader et
de prendre du bon temps une tendance qui
se confirme auprès de nombreuses autres
destinations montagnarde en effet
l'observatoire savoie mont blanc estime
à 70 7% le taux de remplissage moyen des
stations sur nos deux départements et
sur l'ensemble de ces vacances scolaires
voilà est depuis ce week-end marque
aussi l'envoi des jeux olympiques
d'hiver de pékin deux semaines de
compétition qui verront s'affronter les
meilleurs athlètes du monde entier mais
avant de devenir champion olympique
encore faut-il des buts et faire ses
premiers pas sur les skis alors pour
cela rien de mieux que quelques pistes
verte sécurisée nous nous sommes rendus
dans les vosges à la station de ski de
la schult qui est apprécié des débutants
pour son cadre et pour son calme
reportage en pente douce d'anaïs galles
pour vosges télévision regarder
à 1200 mètres d'altitude niché au coeur
de la forêt vosgienne il est un petit
domaine qui fait le bonheur des
débutants à la station de ski de la
schlucht pas besoin de faire la queue
pour monter sur le télésiège les pistes
sont bien larges et assez peu fréquenté
un cadre idéal pour s'essayer en douceur
aux sports d'hiver
ici on a deux pistes de piste bleue
qui sont en fait adapté aux débutants
aux familles il cherche un petit peu
plus de tranquillité des pistes faciles
avec ses 600 mètres de piste et une
affluence qui ne dépasse pas 800
visiteurs lors des plus grosses journées
quand le domaine de la bresse ont fait
plus de dix mille la station de la
schlucht semble en effet rassuré les
skieurs comme une première étape avant
d'entamer la saison c'est quand même ça
fait quelques années que la fée skieurs
ses soeurs de reprendre un peu que je
trouve que c'est l'idéal pour apprendre
ya pas trop et puis
c'est toujours agréable les enfants
adorent venir ici parce qu'ils vont
faire un petit tour dans la forêt voilà
et c'est aussi ça qui fait
l'attractivité du domaine sa situation
géographique c'est aussi un point de
départ pour les randonnées en raquette
le ski de fond un qui est présent du
côté des trois fours et du côté du on
alors sur le lac blanc là bas
c'est assez prisé wayport tout ce qui
est randonnée nordique choses comme ça
sans parler des réaménagements dont le
col a fait l'objet depuis deux ans avec
le nouvel espace de parking et le chalet
tetra 1139 qui sont de vrais plus value
pour l'activité touristique pour
profiter de la poudreuse à la schlucht
compter 16h50 par adulte le forfait à la
journée avec possibilité de louer son
matériel au pied des pistes il n'ya plus
qu'à se laisser glisser
voilà effet dans l'actualité sous l'eau
une triste montagne de déchets vous
allez voir à montpellier plusieurs
associations locales ont organisé une
collecte de déchets sur les rives de
l'étang du méjean ce site pourtant
protégé et classé réserve natura 2000 ne
restent pas moins pollué par de nombreux
résidus en tout genre bilan un triste
spectacle qui aura permis au moins de
sensibiliser quelques passants reportage
de wall and l'est de la rédaction de vie
occitanie sur place
c'est un spectacle de désolation à
montpellier une centaine de bénévoles
découvre avec horreur que le méjean 1
étant classé réserve natura 2000 regorge
de déchets poubelles bouteilles de gaz
roux pour ces kayakistes et ses
plongeurs bénévoles aujourd'hui c'est la
stupeur
c'est impressionnant c'est
impressionnant je m'attendais pas à
trouver autant de pneus de goûter de gaz
des choses franchement c'est triste
quand même des déchets venus tout droit
du lez même au bord de l'eau il ne faut
que quelques minutes pour trouver l'un
des déchets les plus dévastateurs que le
sac il est principalement constituée de
polystyrène en fait et c'est vraiment
horrible parce que en fait face à se
démultiplie en des milliards du nano
particules donc c'est très polluant
derrière cette action greenpeace
rejoints par quatre autres associations
pour sensibiliser le public ils vont
jusqu'à exposer leurs récoltes sur ce
pan à la vue des promeneurs stupéfait
mais je suis très étonné d'y en avoir
autant je pense pas que c'était possible
qu'ils aient autant d'ordures dans les
états une sensibilisation que greenpeace
souhaite intensifier dans les écoles
c'est donc à travers cette pétition
destinée aux institutions que
l'association espère trouver gain de
cause les réduire à la source c'est
quand même la base c'est hyper important
de réfléchir à encore plus aller plus
loin dans la réduction des déchets à la
source on voit encore aujourd'hui des
des magasins qui ne demandent pas si on
veut un emballage ou pas fan je veux
dire il ya beaucoup beaucoup de choses à
faire une pétition disponible sur le
site internet greenpeace montpellier les
opérations de ce type sont appelés à
être renouvelé tous les deux mois dans
la ville
voilà et puis en corse le déploiement de
la fibre optique se poursuit dans les
territoires ruraux et de montagne pour
répondre aux questions de la population
les opérateurs n'hésitent pas à se
déplacer avec un bus itinérant dans les
communes connecter pour renseigner les
usagers à bord du camion des techniciens
répondre aux problèmes rencontrés
parfois lors de l'installation exemple
dans le village de parent a zoo à
quelques encablures de l'île rousse
propos recueillis par pierre pasqualini
et noah teillac de la chaîne locale via
télé pas eu
des problèmes bien évident et sont liées
souvent à des problèmes d'adressage
c'est à dire que dans les communes il
n'ya pas d'adressent il n'y a pas de
voie il ya pas de numéro un du tout donc
c'est un peu compliqué dès fois
d'arriver à trouver un nos propres
clients quand ça dressage et préfet
c'est pour ça que la collectivité de
corse s'est lancée dans un programme
pour aider les communes à réaliser leur
propre adressage avec un numéro un
nombre de voix en plus en favorisant la
langue corse et en numéro en main
permettant un point de géolocalisation
sur toutes les maisons on a des micro
entreprises qui travaillent et en
télétravail et qui ont besoin de deux
haut débit pour pour leurs facturations
pour leurs devis et compagnie c'est vrai
que ça va les aider après non la une
poste communal fumel à des produits qui
eux aussi auraient besoin d'un bon débit
et même pour eux ça va être bien
voilà sans transition les agents de la
police nationale seront bientôt revêtu
d'un nouvel uniforme vous l'avez vu dans
les titres de ce journal une première
depuis 20 ans et après le dernier design
conçu par la célèbre maison balenciaga
ce sont des étudiants d'écoles de mode
et de design qui ont repensé la nouvelle
tenue de la police vous allez voir parmi
eux une école bordelaise une fierté
évidemment pour les étudiants et les
enseignants reportage d'amandine bretons
ce pour télé 7 la chaîne du groupe sud
ouest à bordeaux dès le premier semestre
2011 22 les policiers seront vêtus d'un
nouvel uniforme imaginée et dessinée
notamment par 24 étudiants de cette
école de mode bordelaise le confort
principalement comme ils vont sur le
terrain quelque chose de solide donc ils
ont beaucoup de jeunes et donc avec le
frottement extérieur au pacs à suez
quelque chose de rassurant donc toujours
avec le fait de battre sur le terrain et
de courir d'être en mouvement avec une
école de poitiers ils ont remporté un
appel à projets lancé par le ministère
de l'intérieur le polo et le couvre-chef
ont ainsi été repensé ici avec pour
mission de rapprocher la police du
citoyen grâce à une tenue moderne et
adapté au terrain on a joué sur les
coupes du polo en fait on allait
chercher les tendances que nous on
pouvait porte en tant que citoyen pour
les adapter à eux les couleurs aussi
ensuite on a travaillé un peu sur la
nouvelle griffe du coup parce qu'il
voulait l'intégrer sur les nouveaux
polos m'a aussi jouer bien sûr d
des détails techniques que nous avaient
demandé qu'il est gêné quand il était en
service le couvre-chef qui était jusqu'à
présent une casquette avec une visière
s'est transformé en cas l'eau pour qu'il
n'y ait plus de barrière entre le
policier et le citoyen et pour imaginer
cette tenue les étudiants de cette école
ne sont pas restés à leur bureau et un
de mieux que l'idée qu'ont eu ces
étudiants de se déplacer d'aller à la
rencontre de patrouille pour poser la
question aux policiers qu'est ce que
vous attendez d'une nouvelle tenue c'est
juste une grande fierté est coincé on
marque l'histoire en fait on marque
l'histoire des sucs mode mais aussi de
la police nationale n'oublions pas quand
même que l'on passe derrière valencia
gars donc c'est énorme pour nos
étudiants une conception et une
fabrication 100 % française la
production est en cours dans une usine
du lot livraison prévue au premier
semestre 2022
voilà les célébration d'un anniversaire
maintenant dans le grand jt des
territoires celui de l'euro qui fête ses
20 ans en circulation le 1er janvier
2002 vous vous en souvenez peut-être la
monnaie unique devenez commune pour
douze pays européens dont la france à
l'époque il fallait sortir les
calculettes pour faire les conversion en
francs
vingt ans plus tard où en est on
rencontre avec des passionnés à amiens
avec jérôme ouvrons de la rédaction de
wéo tv la chaîne de la voix du nord
regardez
depuis 2002 ces petites pièces de métal
se sont invités dans nos porte monnaie
il y a 20 ans l'euro monnaie unique
européenne poussée celui qu'on appelait
le nouveau franc vers la sortie
un temps que les moins de vingt ans ne
peuvent pas connaître
c'était pas pareil en fait il y avait
les pièces des différends avec les
pièces de 1 franc j'ai gardé quelques
pièces en monnaie par des souvenirs bon
j'ai quelques nouveautés lefranc un
lointain souvenir pas pour tout le monde
je pense à pois pascal et
collectionneurs et plus précisément de
francs des quatrième et cinquième
république il connaît chaque symbole
frapper sur les devises chaque visage
imprimés sur les billets et l'histoire
qu'il raconte si vous prenez une pièce
qui a le coq dessus pourquoi ils ont mis
un coq parce que le coq représente la
vigilance du peuple français c'est tous
ces petits détails là c'est l'histoire
de leur pièce qui m'intéresse olivier
lui aussi numismate il joue
l'intermédiaire entre les
collectionneurs déniche les pièces rares
les estiment les vents si certaines
pièces frappées à seulement quelques
exemplaires peuvent coûter cher d'autres
ont avant tout une valeur symbolique
comme ce franc morlhon estampillé de la
croix de lorraine témoins de la seconde
guerre mondiale une place de la
résistance elle est historique en fin de
compte à l'époque 7 sont les résistances
d'asseoir leur poche c'est un petit
matin entre eux qu'ils s'envoient et
qu'ils s'envoyaient
l'afl toi 80 ans après je les ai dans ma
main frappé pour la première fois en 13
160 le franc a traversé sept cents ans
d'histoire le temps de se faire une
place auprès des collectionneurs
du haut de ses 20 ans l'euro fait moins
rêver les numismates il lui reste encore
quelques années pour les faire changer
d'avis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on ouvre à présent une page sports dans
ce journal la coupe de france de
football a réservé de belles surprises
pour les clubs amateurs versa et
notamment dans les yvelines s'est
qualifié pour la première fois de son
histoire en quarts de finale après une
victoire historique contre toulouse le
club de la cité royale attendait donc
avec impatience de connaître son nouvel
adversaire après son exploit et le
tirage au sort lui a été plutôt
favorable puisque les versailles et
affronteront mercredi prochain les
autres amateurs encore en lice bergerac
une belle occasion de poursuivre l'
aventure les coulisses du tirage au sort
avec la rédaction de tv 78 dans les airs
ils rêvaient tous d'un autre tirage mais
finalement le sort en a décidé autrement
le football-club de versailles
rencontrera à l'extérieur en quarts de
finale de la coupe de france l'autre
petit poucet de la compétition bergerac
deux clubs de nationale 2 chacun leader
de sa poule en championnat et chacun
déterminés à accéder au dernier carré au
delà de jouer bergerac on est surtout
triste de devoir recevoir pour notre
public ça reste un match de coupe quand
même mais c'est surtout une place qui
jouant pour la demi finale et on va tout
donner de façon on se dit que tout est
possible pour aller en demi finale a
réuni lundi soir pour assister à
l'annoncé des prochaines affiches les
joueurs devront donc attendre encore un
peu pour espérer affronter l'un des
clubs de ligue 1 encore en compétition
marseille nantes ou encore monaco en
attendant le déplacement à bergerac et
vainqueur de metz et saint-etienne au
tour précédent est loin d'être gagné
d'avancé ça nous laisse une chance de
dépasser en demi finales même si c'est
une équipe très sérieuse contre laquelle
on va jouer chez eux sur leur terrain ça
va être un peu compliqué mais se donner
les moyens de passer la rencontre se
jouera le 9 février à 18h30 mais quel
que soit le résultat il y aura bien un
club de nationale 2 en demi finale de
coupe de france cette année
voilà et puis on reste dans le football
direction le stade louis ii de monaco où
se déroulait la deuxième édition de la
fight aids cup un match de football
caritatif opposant l'équipe du prince
albert à celle de la princesse stéphanie
une rencontre avec de nombreuses stars
comme le sélectionneur de l'équipe de
france didier deschamps ou encore le
pilote de f1 charles leclerc un match
aussi dans la bonne humeur vous allez
voir au profit de l'association de la
lutte contre le hiv fight aids monaco
frédéric et lyon et sylvain peroumal
étaient sur place pour la rédaction de
monaco il faut regarder
les héros de l'épopée de ligue des
champions en 2004 ludovic giuly jérôme
rothen toto schillaci ou encore flavio
roma des anciennes stars du ballon rond
comme youri djorkaeff clarence seedorf
ou didier deschamps tous étaient réunis
lundi soir au stade louis 2 pour la
deuxième édition de la faillite et scope
un match caritatif au profit de
l'association fight aids monaco
opposants à l'ébarbage mans en rouge
l'équipe du prince albert ii au cirque
fc maillot bleu la formation de la
princesse stéphanie
après deux mi temps de trente cinq
minutes et grâce un doublé de l'ancien
attaquant italien du bayern munich luca
toni le cirque fc s'impose 2-1 et
soulève le trophée là c'était un petit
peu le on va dire le conflit sympa avec
louis donc et le capitaine de notre
équipe ça fait un mois que
voilà puis il me dit que son équipe
était au top elle était prête moi de mon
côté je disais la même chose donc on
s'est un petit peu gentiment chambrer
encore une belle réussite du monde des
beaux noms mais aussi un score qui est
toujours pas en notre faveur on va
espérer faire mieux l'année prochaine
c'était top j'ai pris du plaisir comme
d'habitude après le talent est toujours
pas là à chaque fois je je je je viens
sur un terrain je m'améliore pas donc ça
c'est dommage mais bon d'un autre côté
c'était pour la bonne cause donc
vraiment content d'avoir fait partie de
ce match c'est presque un devoir pour
nous de faire des des choses bien et
comme ce soir pour fighters avec la
princesse stéphanie donc
quand on peut donner de son temps et de
notre carrière pour des bonnes causes je
pense qu'on aime tous le faire et la
troisième édition ne sera pas la semaine
prochaine mais l'an prochain avec encore
une fois deux grands noms du football
réunie à monaco pour la bonne cause
voilà ce qu'ont toujours dans ce journal
avec cette initiative originale du club
de hand ball professionnel de toulouse
les phénix comme on les appelle là bas
ont passé une journée dans la peau de
salariés de leurs partenaires lidl un
vis ma vie dans la bonne humeur au
qu'elle a pu assister clément gaci
écouter ses réactions au micro de nos
confrères de la dépêche du midi c'est la
première fois que je suis en train de
bien faire dès qu'on dirait tout ça donc
c'est génial et d'avoir d'avoir aussi
comment ce concept comme ça se passe ici
comme les français s'étaient bien si ça
permet aussi aux joueurs de sortir un
petit peu de la bulle dans laquelle on
vit nous toute l'année au palais des
sports et quand on vient ici voir des
travaux peut-être un petit peu plus
pénible où il faut porter les choses
je pense que ça leur fait du bien aussi
de se reconnecter à la vraie vie de tous
les jours voilà c'est la fin de ce grand
jt des territoires merci de nous avoir
suivi sur vos chaînes locales et
régionales de la tnt et sur tv5 monde on
se retrouve très vite pour une prochaine
édition aura tous
[Musique]